all right let's go to california now
where voters will decide tomorrow if
governor gavin newsom should be thrown
out of office the latest poll suggests
that more than half of voters plan to
vote against the recall in essence in
favor of the governor and that is a much
wider margin in favor of that democrat
than six weeks ago president biden will
campaign with newsome at a rally tonight
and our major garrett is in california
where the governor is lumping his
opponents together under a single name
we will defeat this republican-backed
recall on tuesday
governor gavin newsom rallied union and
latino voters in los angeles sunday and
later warned that republican
front-runner larry elder is a new
version of donald trump
we would put ourselves on a very
dangerous course if we do not
overwhelmingly show up and reject this
recall effort that means donald trump's
on the ballot in your opinion oh
trumpism is
donald trump was defeated last november
but trump as it hasn't been defeated we
asked elder a nationally syndicated talk
show host and columnist about the former
president donald trump is irrelevant to
this election it's not irrelevant to you
though the only people they ever bring
up donald trump are the media and newsom
and former president obama who cut a tv
commercial featuring elder and mr trump
protect california by voting no
on the republican recall all part of a
concerted democratic effort to save
newsom one that has enlisted the vice
president bernie sanders and elizabeth
warren a lot of people have come in from
outside the state including president
barack obama cutting commercials for him
bernie sanders has cut a commercial for
him senator warren has cut a commercial
for him
and no one's uttered the following words
gavin newsom has done a good job for
california under recall rules a majority
of voters have to vote yes to oust
newsom if that happens then the top vote
getter among 46 challengers becomes
governor no matter how small their share
of the vote republicans blame newsome
for mismanaging california's homeless
population and for going too far they
say with pandemic lockdown orders and
mask mandates first day i'm going to
repeal any mandate for state workers
that require them to be tested and to
wear a mask at work i don't believe the
science supports that so that mandate
will be repealed before i had my first
cup of tea elder also recently said the
recall was already marred by quote
shenanigans and subject to fraud but
when we raised that with elder he seemed
to back off so many people are going to
vote to recall him it won't matter what
what kind of shenanigans if there are
any that take place republican rivals
kevin faulconer former two-term mayor of
san diego and self-funded businessman
john cox who lost handily to newsome in
2018 accused elder of scaring off voters
with baseless claims of fraud
it's a dead end because if you tell
people their vote isn't going to be
counted correctly they're not going to
vote claiming before the election's even
over that it's going to be stolen is
wrong there's absolutely no basis for
that at all
and major garrett joins us now from los
angeles major good morning to you i
believe this is effort number six on
behalf of republicans to recall governor
newsom first one to go to a vote what
made it different
well this one qualified tony that's what
made it different the previous ones
didn't and one of the reasons this
qualified you need 1.5 million
signatures in california to do that
is because
republican backers of the recall got
extra time to collect signatures why
because of coveted lockdown restrictions
one of the few times that those
restrictions pleased republicans the
judge said actually it's hard to do that
when you can't knock on doors or meet
people face to face and in that
intervening period of time governor
newsom went to what is now in california
probably one of the most famous dinners
of all time he went to a place called
the french laundry in napa an exclusive
some might say elitist restaurant he did
so with lobbyists he didn't wear a mask
and he wasn't socially distant at the
very time he was urging californians to
stay home wear masks and socially
distant many voters here told us that
act of hypocrisy drove them to sign the
petition to bring us to where we are now
where he faces a potential recall
yeah as the kids say that was not a good
look for the governor the optics were
really bad so
major what else is at stake for the
democrats do you think
california democrats tell us a couple of
things minimum wage abortion the entire
progressive agenda dealing with climate
change and taxation in california is at
stake here national democrats see
broader implications they see the
governor's closing argument emphasizing
two things as a potential template for
the 2022 midterm elections what is that
template reinforcing that science-based
decisions on mandates whether it's
vaccines testing or masks work
practically and politically and portray
whoever your republican opponent is as
some kind of echo of donald trump or the
trump agenda
well they say it all depends on turnout
as it always does we'll know tomorrow
thank you very much major